you
[Applause]
Sentinel is a proactive early warning
system to preempt pandemics it is built
on three major pillars the first pillar
is detect Cristiano I've been studying
infectious diseases together around the
world for two decades we've been using
genome sequencing reading out the
complete genetic information of a
microbe it allows us to identify viruses
even those we've never seen before
track them as they spread and watch for
new mutations and now with the powerful
gene editing technology CRISPR we can
use this genetic information to rapidly
design exquisitely sensitive diagnostic
tests for any microbe one of these tools
is called Shella it can be used to test
non viruses on simple paper strips it is
very inexpensive and front-right health
workers can use cello to detect the most
common or most threatening viruses
within an hour the other tool is Carmen
it requires a lab but it can test for
hundreds of viruses simultaneously so
hospital lab staff can test patient
samples for a broad range of viruses
within a day our second pillar is
connect connect everyone and share this
information across the public health
community most outbreaks hospital staff
see our case information through paper
Excel if at all this makes tracking an
outbreak through space and time and
coordinating a response extremely
difficult so we're developing a
cloud-based system and mobile
applications that connect community
health workers clinicians Public Health
teams everyone and allows them to upload
data perform analysis share insights and
coordinate a response and action plan in
real time a third pillar is in power
hardware surveillance system can only
succeed if we empower frontline health
workers that are already out there
taking care of communities it requires a
lot of training Paris and I are very
much aware of that we spend a 5-10 years
training hundreds of young African
scientists and clinicians over the next
five years who would train an additional
1,000 workers to use Sentinel detection
tools and empower them to train their
colleagues this way we will improve the
original hacker system and integrate
surveillance into medical practices
so here we are it's we're recording this
it's April 7th 2020 and obviously we are
in the throes of this crazy global
pandemic caused by this new corona virus
so you two have been working together
forever and who really came together
pretty aggressively went with the Ebola
crisis back in 2014 what does it feel
like from your perspective pretty much
as six years after the mole outbreak
we're really facing another crisis and
we're still pretty much like we never
learned from the previous crisis and
that's really for me is heartbreaking I
think that the that this pandemic has
shown us how unprepared that we are
everywhere in the world Christian and
our partners together had Diagnostics at
our hospital sites in Nigeria Sierra
Leone and Senegal in early February most
states in the United States didn't have
it for far later it's it's very it it
tells us you know that we are all in
this together and we are all very much
behind the curve
so this sentinel system is amazing but I
know that the question that's on
everybody's mind is how is that playing
into the here and now
you know we describe Sentinel as a
pandemic preemption system and here we
are in a pandemic but what's great it's
actually the same tools you need to
preempt a pandemic are the ones that you
need to respond to one and so all of the
technologies that we have laid out the
point-of-care testing the multiplex
testing the discovery of and tracking of
the viruses it's changing and that
overlay of the mobile applications to
dashboard are all critical for us it is
a war
we're basically committed for 24 hours
turnaround time do you know that to give
results and and that requires for us to
walk around the clock non-stop so it's a
it's a pretty challenging moment we're
away from family at least I have a
privilege to see family today and then
I'm sure you know tomorrow I'm heading
back in the trenches in my lab we second
the first kovat night in genome on the
African continent and then that really
was done within 48 hours and this is
revolutionary you know coming from
Africa and then making this information
available for the global health
community to see what a virus with
in Africa looks like I believe that with
technologies and knowledge and then
sharing information we can do better and
if we can overcome the whole idea of
sentinels that we all stand guard over
each other we all watch each one of us
is a sentinel each one of us being able
to monitor what is making us sick can
share that with the rest of our
community and I think that is that is
what I you know profoundly want is for
us to all stand guard and watch over
each other
[Music]